Okay, here is my solution for a valid year.
It's almost identifical to valid day. We take in a year.
First, we make sure it's all digits, then we convert it to an integer.
Then we check to see if it's within 1900 and 2020,
and if it is, we return it.
Let's go ahead and test this.
Okay, I'll start with a valid year--1995.
We'll run this. That works.
Let's try another year--2000. Let's try that. That works. 2000.
Let's try an invalid year--1875.
If any of our users were born in 1875, they're probably not going to enjoy using our web app.
Okay, so it returned none as we expected.
Let's try some junk strings to make sure our function doesn't blow up.
Also returning none.
Let's try another string that's too big--2300.
Also prints none, so our function is good.
Alright, good job! Let's move on.